the jurgen experience so
so we would sit there and it was right
before he got saturday night live what
year was
uh 86 it was one year
before he got that and before i i had
been in a richard pryor movie that was
the first thing of consequence and then
what movie was that critical condition
you got to work with pryor i got to
spend a month with him
and i got to hang out with him cause i
was one of the hosts at the store for
eight years
and you got to work with pryor when
prior was prior well it was after the
fire
but it was still what was hundred
percent sunset's trip was
under the fire it was after the fire joe
dancer
uh it was and and critical condition was
directed by michael laptop
great director who did uh coal miner's
daughter made a lot of important moves
did the seven up series do you ever see
that seven up 14 up 21 up
took seven people through their lives
from london and followed them every
seven years did a documentary about them
oh wow it's just a real special
brilliant lovely man
he was head of the academy for a while
anyway so what happened
but but um but working with prior we
were
you know when you're doing a movie we
were in a shower stall in an old
hospital
and it's supposed to be uh rikers island
or
whatever the hell that prison is up
there is that
is it rikers which one in new york
what's the um i think that's rikers
right
yeah yeah i think that's what it was it
was representing that but we shot it in
high point north carolina with really
good actors joe montagna
and reuben blades and all these randall
text cops some really cool
oh [ __ ] cool weird eclectic group
and um i just watched him the other day
in raising arizona he's a great actress
that's great man
that movie was that movie was wild
that's one of the be that's
that low point of view shot in the
supermarket
the image images and that in a lot of
cone brothers movies they're the best
come on [ __ ] [ __ ] i love big brother
big lebowski is
my wife every day it's like let's just
watch the big lebowski
you know she's a classic man it's a dude
floating in space man
sorry i was interrupting you so you're
working well that's what i do with prior
so we're in a shower stall and um
and we became friends we would go to
dinner
i would i i was the guy i'm i'm always
wanting to make things better somehow
i was raised that way by my dad and my
mom to try to make
peace for people that's the thing and
and he liked that i would invite him
because people didn't invite him to [ __ ]
because he was
kind of unapproachable to some people so
we would go to dinner and we would laugh
and i would make him laugh we
had to do one scene 40 takes because one
shot
that was a long steady cam shot we had a
dead body in it was covered in water
and i was supposed to say something like
oh the guy was in the drink we found it
but it was such a
fake looking body and every time i said
this serious line i was this young
doctor
richard just cracked up and so he's
looking in my face and there's no bigger
honor
look at you baby face [ __ ] [ __ ]
how old were you then
uh 26 27.
and wow that was a good scene
as ruben wow i remember all of this
really that he and i
so he couldn't the fact that he couldn't
look in my face
and kept laughing and it was a serious
scene do you know what an
honor that is oh man so the guy was an
idol
so i'm i'm sitting in the shower with
him and he shows me this thing this is
graphic he shows me the scrubbing brush
and one side's soft the other side is
just bristles
and he says i don't think he'd mind me
telling you this i always think about
when you talk about someone that you
love
that's deceased would they be okay with
what you're saying
so it's not tmz garbage so he would take
the
the hard scrubbing part and he said this
is what this is what they took my skin
off with
after the fire they had to scrub my
whole body with this [ __ ]
and i'm just sat there and i i remember
crying
i i think there was a the combined
empathy and then i told him of
like my sister that died and then he was
telling me you know you just get close
with people
and then one night i didn't invite him
to dinner because he'd had a hard day
and he was mad at me the next day and i
was like oh my god so he was enjoying
so i said but he but he was he was in a
rough place he was you know
not he was complicated human but i i
remember saying too
because when you're acting you just i
don't know i was green
i said so you're upset with me i'm so
sorry
this means we're friends right because i
upset you right
and then he went we went to dinner again